thank you and now to present the award
for the best cartoon the child star of
the bad scene who killed the critics and
most of the cast
miss patty McCormack
good evening mr. Lewis don't you point
that at me it might be loaded baby you
don't have to be afraid of a little girl
like me I don't have to be afraid of a
little girl like you why I'm only ten
years old born in Lebanon and I'm only
31 and I'm going on whom phenomena best
car to Steven resist down producer for
Joe McBrine born on Planet move Steven
vasista for the Jay Walker and Steven
possessed down for mr. Magoo's puddle
jumper something tells me mr. possessed
out just might win
yeah have you had no please
mr. Magoo's puddle jumper Steven Gazoo
stop
Lindy furnace will accept the award for
mr. resistor I'm sure you all know it
but I feel I must say it it's not a
one-man job thank you
thank you very much and I'm telling you
one thing if this little kid doesn't win
an award tonight I'm going home in a cab
I ain't get to my car and stepping on
his daughter I tell you that
better date with Peter Lorre this child